حظر تجول لا تعجبني كلمة حظر تجول
حاول أبي فرض حظر تجول بالنسبة لي ، لم
أتجاوز الاستياء أبدًا ، لكنني أعتقد
أنك ستراني لأن الأرقام لا تبطئ
مشاكلك مع تبادلات حظر التجول
فقط حتى تعرف  لم أجد أبدًا أنك
انتهكت حظر التجول طوال الوقت تسبب في
الكثير من الألم ولكن هذه قصة مختلفة
لا أؤمن بالقواعد الحاكم أندرو
كومو.
أنت تعمل بجد من أجل
ولايتك ، ولكن بغض النظر عن مدى صعوبة
عملك ، فهناك دائمًا وقت للاتصال بأمي ،
فهي تريد أن تسمع منك فقط حتى
تعرف ، نعم ، اتصلت بأمي ، لقد اتصلت بأمي
قبل مجيئي في هذا العرض بالمناسبة
قالت إنني كنت المفضلة لديها ، لم تقل
أبدًا أخبارًا جيدة هي أنها قالت إنك كنت
ابنها المفضل الثاني
كريستوفر ،
كلانا يعرف أنه لا أحد منا من الأمهات
المفضل الأول أو الثاني في العائلة
لا أصدق أنك تكذب على
جمهوري  لقد فجرت المصداقية
ويجب أن أجري المقابلة بأكملها  لقد
أنهيت ابنك المفضل الثاني ، استمع إلى
العالم ،
استمع إلى السياسيين صعبون للغاية ، ألقوا
كلمة هناك بعد المرة الأولى
التي قلت فيها إنها تثير الكثير من الشك ،
لكني أتخيل أنك أوضحت ليس لي
مباشرة عبر اللوحة ، ابق مستقيماً
عبر اللوحة ابق مستقيماً  إقامة قوية
لشعبك وأنا أقدر وجودك
هنا بحبك يا أخي
يوتيوب